[Music]
from Destiny's Child to a child of her
own
in her new book whoa baby Kelly Rowland
gets real about life as a new mom she
welcomed her son Titan in November 2014
the physical changes that was definitely
the challenge in it all we talk about
sex after baby it's you know your
sensuality and sexuality is a woman and
you know finding your your judge again
how to change your sex life you talk
about that in the book you know at that
six-week period feels like forever I'm
like no let's get this thing rocking
again let's let the shop back open yeah
yeah absolutely I still a mom and it
doesn't matter I'm a woman and I have
physical needs you're very open and
honest about the changes that your body
took after having a baby so how did you
get back to where you are today and
feeling like yourself again for me it
was really about nutrition and it was
about finding a trainer who could really
understand my body and the things that
it was going through and you talked
about wanting to get another boob job
why you know it the the feeding does
take a toll on your lovely girls you
know you just always want them to sit up
and look like they're just you know 21
again oh but everything does change and
you know if the time came and that
needed to be done then we'll just kick
him back up now would you wait for the
next baby or until you're outwardly done
I would wait definitely what would be
the one piece of advice that you would
give a new mom who has no idea what's to
come the one piece of advice I would
give her it's not to be so hard on
herself I think as a new mom you just
kind of have this thing to where you
feel like you just have to figure
everything out for yourself I would say
ask for help if you need it like can you
watch the baby for like ten minutes I
just need to take a shower we're so busy
pouring into the baby we're so busy
pouring into our marriages or you know
relationships that we forget about
ourselves and we really need to be
fueled back up if we're left on empty
then what do we have
[Music]